[Music]
item concealing candles mysterious wall
meet monsters there's only one series I
could be talking about and that's
Castlevania the eternal battle between
the Belmont bloodline and Dracula has
been chronicled in videogames over the
past three decades spanning from the
Famicom and NES
to the ps3 and 360 yes unfortunately
it's been quite some time since we've
been able to brandish a whip swinging it
at everything from jumping skeletons to
flying medusa heads and more and while
we're looking forward with hopeful
hearts that more Castlevania will one
day come we decided now would be a great
time to look back at the history of
Vampire Killers
[Music]
the series started way back in 1986 on
the Famicom disk system released only in
Japan and under the name Akuma Jo
Dracula the game saw huge success
prompting Konami to create a version for
the Nintendo Entertainment System and
bring it to western regions it was
released one year later in 1987 under a
new name
Castlevania the name change happened due
to the overall avoidance of religious
themes in Nintendo of America's video
games during the 80s and 90s with Akuma
Joe Dracula translating roughly to demon
Castle Dracula Konami of America went
with a new moniker Castlevania was what
they went with most likely because the
game is about a castle and Transylvania
is intrinsic with vampire lore as for
the actual game itself Castlevania is a
side-scrolling platformer that sees the
player controlling Simon Belmont as he
makes his way through Dracula's castle
to ultimately fight and kill the Lord of
Darkness your main weapon is a whip
which becomes more powerful and longer
as you collect the appropriate power-ups
you'll also come across various sub
weapons such as holy water a boomerang
like cross and a throwing knife using
these sub weapons cost hearts which is
basically the Castlevania series version
of manna the levels mostly have you
moving from the left side of a room to
the right but at times you'll climb a
set of stairs and make your way back to
the left on a different floor this
wasn't something you saw much in this
era as most games of this side-scrolling
ilk prevented backwards progress and of
course you'll come across a large
variety of enemies along the way mostly
inspired by the classic Universal
monster movies each level is broken up
into three stages the beginning of which
you'll be transported back to if you die
and if you lose all of your lives you'll
be sent back to the very beginning of
the level
eventually you'll reach a boss room that
has you fighting characters like mummies
Frankenstein and death himself the
Castlevania games are notorious for
their difficulty with the bosses serving
as the cherry on top of that unforgiving
cake this is where most players have
come up with what you may call cheesy
strategies to conquer them
[Music]
but in Castlevania the bosses aren't
necessarily the scariest foes each enemy
is capable of killing you or seriously
endangering your run as the last while
there are boats and platforming
Castlevania is all about learning what
each enemy is capable of and how best to
deal with them whether it's mastering
the flight path of a medusa head the
timing of a bone pillars fireballs or
the throwing arc of the skeletons bones
you need to learn each monsters
intricacies to effectively make your way
through the levels and its bosses this
combat mastery is the heart and soul of
Castlevania something that permeates
each subsequent entry in the series a
game that seems now impossible turns
manageable once you master your enemies
patterns
[Music]
since its release Castlevania has
effectively become videogame royalty one
of the undeniable classics of the NES
era
unfortunately however we don't actually
know for sure who created it during this
time in Japanese video game development
many people use pseudonyms in the
credits of games the reason for this is
commonly believed to have been away for
companies to prevent their employees
from being poached with the Castlevania
credits being full of parodies of
Universal monster movies it's not
immediately clear who did what many fans
believe that a Hitoshi a Komatsu was the
creator of Castlevania it's known that
he directed the NES games but he seemed
to disappear from the industry in the
early 90s no one has been able to track
him down
since now while Castlevania was the
first in the series to make its way to
North America there was actually a
different game that came to Europe first
this was vampire killer on the msx2
computer and while it shared many
similarities to the first Castlevania
there were also some significant
differences the most notable is the lack
of side-scrolling with single flip
screens being used instead this was due
to the fact that the MSX two's technical
limitations made scrolling quite
difficult to pull off however the
differences don't end there
vampire killers levels were less linear
and tasked players with finding the
skeleton key and exit to the next level
treasure chests and merchants also
populate the castle with the latter
offering players new items at the cost
of hearts vampire killer released in
Japan as Akuma Joe Dracula a month after
the Famicom disk system version and
because it released in Europe before the
NES version came westward it doesn't
feature the Castlevania branding and
while the vampire killer name didn't
stick as the Series title it did
eventually become the name of the
legendary whip wielded by the Belmont
family
kastlevania to Simon's quest was up next
for the series and released in 1987 in
Japan on the Famicom disk system while
the NES version came to North America in
1988 it served as a direct sequel to the
first game continuing the story several
years after Dracula's defeat in that
fateful battle Simon Belmont was cursed
to undo this curse Simon must find five
pieces of Dracula's body resurrect him
and then vanquished the Lord of Darkness
for good Simon's quest was quite
ambitious for its time implementing an
open-world RPG elements and a day and
night cycle
during the day Simon can talk to various
towns folk to buy supplies and receive
tips on what to do next
however when nightfall hits enemies get
stronger and the towns folk disappear as
for what you'd buy from these villagers
well you didn't collect wit power-ups
and items by hitting candles instead you
purchase them with hearts so in this
game you actually have to buy better
whips and the stakes that you'll use on
Dracula's body parts Simon's quest
featured a similar combat system to the
original Castlevania but many fans felt
it was considerably less challenging
than its predecessor the easy bosses are
often criticized but it was also more
forgiving if you happen to die as you
would spawn nearby rather than at the
start of the level instead it focused a
lot more of its difficulty on obscure
and perplexing objectives and thanks to
its enigmatic and oftentimes poor
translation players criticized it for
being too cryptic in fact it's become
notorious for these seemingly
nonsensical puzzles and solutions one of
the more infamous ones requires you to
equip a specific item kneel in a
specific spot for a specific amount of
time and wait for a tornado to take you
to a castle
simon's quest is considered in NES
classic by many but its cryptic nature
and format was abandoned with its sequel
in 1989 Akuma drew Densetsu hit the
Famicom in Japan and a year later it
would come westward as Castlevania 3
Dracula's curse
[Music]
Dracula's curse is set prior to the
events of the original Castlevania it
sees Simon's ancestor Trevor Belmont on
a mission to kill Dracula it features
the same style of platforming as the
first game but spices things up with
alternate routes and multiple characters
throughout the game you'll come across
branching paths at which you'll need to
make a decision of which way to go the
first of these choices comes during the
second stage while more branching paths
appear deeper into your adventure you'll
come across different alternate
characters depending on your chosen path
and you won't be able to meet them all
in a single playthrough the new playable
characters include sizeable nadas a
sorceress utilizes powerful spells grant
tenacity a pirate that can climb walls
and stab foes with his dagger and a loo
card the son of Dracula who can shoot
fireballs and turn into a bat each
character joins you after you defeat a
boss whether it's a monster that has
captured them a possessed version of
themselves or in a low cards case a test
to see if you can help him vanquish his
father
like many games in the series
Castlevania 3 has its fair share of
regional differences however in this
game they extend further than just
censoring the naked statues the North
American NES version is actually
considered to be more difficult than its
Famicom counterpart the Famicom version
features a version of grant that
actually throws his dagger and less
punishing checkpoints Dracula himself is
also considered more difficult on the
NES thanks to him using his magic beams
much more frequently the biggest change
however is within the sound the famicom
version contains a specialized sound
chip called the VR c6 which brings two
more pulse wave channels and an extra
saw wave channel to the table this makes
the music sound much more vibrant thanks
to the VR c6 his ability to emulate
elements such as a synth string section
unfortunately the NES is unable to
support external sound chips so the
soundtrack was downgraded for the North
American release
[Music]
a year prior to the release of
Castlevania three we saw this series
make its handheld debut on the Gameboy
this kicked off a sub series of sorts
which saw three releases between 1989
and 1997 the first was Castlevania the
adventure which starred another bailout
family member named Christopher it
featured four stages no sub weapons or
stairs and hearts that replenish your
health instead of mana the adventure saw
remake on the Wii in 2009 as a we were
title called Castlevania the adventure
rebirth this remake had six levels and
unlike its gameboy counterpart five sub
weapons it was received much more
favorably than the original which was
criticized for its technical limitations
now the adventure was met with a sequel
in 1991 called belmonts revenge
Christopher once again takes center
stage as Dracula kidnaps his son turns
him into a demon and reclaims his castle
Belmonts revenge added a level select
and two sub weapons the axe and holy
water the Japanese version on the other
hand featured a cross instead of the axe
[Music]
the last Gameboy game Castlevania
Legends was released six years later in
Japan in 1997 with the North American
release coming a year later this time
you're playing as Sonia the first of the
Belmonts to hunt down Dracula gameplay
is similar to the previous two games but
instead of sub weapons she has soul
weapons which are earned from defeating
bosses like sub weapons these use hearts
as fuel allowing Sonia to perform
various abilities such as freezing
enemies replenishing her health bar and
damaging foes in a variety of ways while
this was positioned as the first game in
the series timeline it was later removed
from the Canon altogether now before we
move on to the 16-bit era were not quite
ready to leave the Famicom just yet
Konami released aku Maggio special boku
Dracula Kuhn in 1990 roughly translated
to Diamond Castle special I'm Kendrick
EULA the game is a spin-off parody of
sorts that features the son of Dracula
on a journey to defeat the evil demon
galimov much like Dracula's other son
Alucard Kid Dracula can throw fireballs
at his enemies it's a much more cheerful
and wholesome game than any other in the
series but unfortunately it never
released outside of Japan three years
later however a sequel released in all
regions on the Gameboy with the dawn of
the 16-bit era came super Castlevania 4
for the Super Nintendo releasing in 1991
it was somewhat of a retelling of the
first Castlevania though it did feature
new mechanics and levels some of which
took place outside of the castle
altogether as such summon must venture
towards Dracula's castle before actually
making his way up to the Dark Lord's
lair while following a linear path in
the same basic format of previous games
super Castlevania 4 allows you to whip
in eight different directions in
addition to swinging it around with the
d-pad while holding the appropriate
button
Simon's whip can also be used to grapple
on to specific points and swing from
platform to platform on top of all that
super Castlevania 4 makes use of the
snes's mode 7 feature which enables a
game's background to be rotated and
scaled this allows for certain games to
look like their 3d super Castlevania for
uses mode 7 most notably in stage 4
where the level rotates in one section
and then twists like a two-man
oh and perhaps the most important thing
is that if you hold the opposite
direction of the d-pad while also
walking up stairs Simon will do a little
moonwalk love your move Simon the next
Castlevania game released exclusively in
Japan well at least at first another
game called Akuma Joe Dracula released
exclusively for the sharp x68000 in 1993
it of course would come to western
regions on the PlayStation in 2001 as
Castlevania chronicles this game is
another remake of the first castlevania
sticking much closer to that original
game than even super Castlevania 4 did
but still featuring new stages enemies
and items the PlayStation re-release
contains this original version but it
also saw the inclusion of an arranged
mode that features new cutscenes and
music in addition to a new Simon Belmont
sprite and balanced changes to the
difficulty level following the sharp
x68000 s Dracula was another japan-only
release aku Maggio Dracula ex Chino
Rondo also known as Rondo of blood
considered by many to be one of the
series best Rondo flood was exclusive to
the PC engine super cd-rom the Japanese
version of the turbo graphic CD it
follows a new Belmont ancestor named
Richter with a story told through anime
cutscenes and Japanese voiceover this
time Dracula is resurrected by the dark
priest shaft and Richter must do what
Belmonts do but wait there's more
Richter's lava net is kidnapped by
Dracula along with three other women one
of those other women is Maria Renard who
once rescued it becomes an alternate
playable character she's considered by
fans to be somewhat of an easy mode
thanks to her faster attacks double jump
and slide as for how richter plays Rondo
focuses on classic Castlevania combat as
opposed to super Castlevania 4s
eight-way whip attacks and flailing
[Music]
[Music]
for the first time however a Castlevania
game would not feature whip upgrades
Richter wields the vampire killer whip
at full strength the meaning you won't
be handicapped with a shorter leather
whip when you die Rondo also brought
back alternate paths
however these aren't clear-cut like they
were in Castlevania 3 there instead
secrets you uncover by breaking certain
walls are falling down specific pits
leading you to new levels in bosses
classic Castlevania sub weapons also
make a return with a new addition in the
Bible which spins around Richter
providing somewhat of a shield and
dealing damage to anyone who touches it
and as is Castlevania custom hearts
still govern how many times you can use
a sub weapon but in Rondo you'll be able
to consume even more hearts to perform a
more dramatic and powerful attack in all
previous games you'd also lose your
current sub weapon if you picked up
another accidental or not
however Rondo will drop the sub weapon
you replaced allowing you to pick it up
again if you so desire now while this
version of Rondo didn't release outside
of Japan a couple remakes have made
their way west the first of these is
Castlevania dracula x which released on
the smash in 1995 known as dracula XX in
japan and vampires kiss in europe this
game is more an adaptation than an
actual remake it features richter as the
main character and some of the same
enemy sprites but the levels are
completely different and while Maria can
still be rescued she is no longer a
playable character the difficulty was
also increased which some fans think is
a good thing
this is especially true when it comes to
the Dracula fight which is known to be a
bit easy in the original Rondo of blood
other players however find Dracula X to
be one of the more frustrating
castlevanias
a more straightforward remake released
for the PSP in 2007 this was dracula ex
chronicles which featured 3d graphics
new cutscenes and slightly reworked
stages one of the most notable was the
final battle with dracula which was
changed to match up more closely to the
beginning of Castlevania Symphony of the
Night difficulty has also been changed
with some areas being much easier while
others much harder other changes include
the addition of unlockable extras that
appears pickups in game two of these
extras are full playable versions of the
original Rondo of blood and Symphony of
the Night however they both feature
redone vo this means that the original
Rondo is in English while much of the
dialogue and Symphony of the Night is
changed these versions of the games are
also the ones included in 2018 requiem
collection on the ps4 next in the series
is 1994's Castlevania bloodlines the
first and only game to release on the
Sega Genesis and it's kind of a sequel
to Bram Stoker's Dracula yes the famous
novel in which the famous count was
created bloodlines follows John Morris
the son of Quincey Morris who landed the
final blow on Dracula in Stoker's novel
however in Castlevania the Morris family
is linked the Belmont clan how they're
connected isn't exactly clear at this
point but with the vampire killer whip
in the hands of the Morris family and
Quincy's untimely death during his
battle with Dracula John must team up
with fellow vampire hunter and Belmont
relative Eric liquor to take on the next
big evil baddie and that baddie is
Elizabeth Bartley who was revived much
like Dracula prior to the events of
Rondo of blood she effectively starts
the first world war to revive Dracula
with the dying Souls which prompts John
and Eric to travel across Europe to wage
war against Bartley much like Dracula is
based on vlad the impaler Bartley is
also partly based on a historical figure
linked with vampires Elizabeth báthory
was an alleged serial killer who was
believed to have killed hundreds of
young women in the late 1500s and early
1600s in Castlevania Bartley is
Dracula's niece and well that family
isn't exactly known for its pacifism
as for bloodlines gameplay well it's a
bit of a mix between
super Castlevania 4 and Rondo of blood
while it's closer to Rondo in terms of
whip gameplay John can't attack
diagonally when jumping and swing on
ceilings
unlike Rondo however it does feature
whip upgrades but the most powerful
being a type of energy whip that can be
lost if you get hints Eric the card on
the other hand uses a magical spear that
was given to his family by a Luo card
the spear can be upgraded the same
number of times as the whip with the
final being a fire spear however it's
ultimately a much more effective weapon
Eric can attack upwards and diagonally
while standing drive his spear downward
while jumping and Fault himself directly
into the air in addition to its greater
reach he can also spin the spear around
him for as long as you hold the
appropriate button and push left and
right on the d-pad
[Music]
when compared to its Super Nintendo and
pc-engine counterparts bloodlines is a
much darker game for example bloodlines
features much more blood and gore than
the previous two games however this was
not the case in all regions in Europe
and Australia all mentions of blood were
removed this includes when it's seen in
various levels and the title screen
which features blood dripping into a sea
of gore and because of the title its
European name is Castlevania the new
generation while in Japan it's known as
vampire killer with super Castlevania 4
Rondo and bloodlines behind it konami z'
next move with the Castlevania series
was a big one
one that in some ways would redefine the
series direction for the next decade but
first we need to rewind a bit prior to
the development of Rondo of blood a
young programmer named Koji Igarashi
started working at Konami he worked on a
business sim game that was cancelled
before becoming a programmer on to Tana
twinby and the dating sim tokimeki
memorial both for the PC engine his
future wife was working on Rondo of
blood at a time a game he would play on
his time off and after the development
of tokimeki memorial he requested a
transfer from this point forward he
worked as part of the Castlevania team
work began on the follow up to
bloodlines which was set to release for
Sega 32x add-on for the Genesis this
game was ultimately cancelled and if it
wasn't for Igarashi we wouldn't know
much about it talking to one up in 2012
Igarashi said we made an early playable
version but the game did not progress
because our company's policy towards the
hardware changed management decided to
make the playstation our focus so we
made some drastic changes to our initial
ideas and ended up with symphony of the
night and in 1997 Castlevania Symphony
of the Night released for the original
PlayStation the game opens with the
retelling of Richter Belmont fateful
battle with Dracula and the collapse of
the Dark Lord's castle what is a man a
miserable little pile of secrets but
enough talk how about you however five
years later it rises unexpectedly and
with the disappearance of Richter
Alucard takes it upon himself to find
out what's going on he comes across many
of the classic Castlevania enemies as he
ventures deeper into the castle
including a familiar face Maria Renard
the twelve-year-old vampire hunter from
Rondo of blood compared to the Belmonts
a loo card is a much more agile fighter
wielding a wide array of weapons spells
and abilities unfortunately for him
death appears shortly after a loo card
enters the castle and steals his entire
arsenal leaving him to venture Dracula's
lair to reclaim it this is where
Symphony of the Night differs most from
previous games the entirety of the
castle is free and open for you to
explore however there are areas you just
won't be able to access without the
right powers you can gain these powers
by collecting relics which allow you to
double jump turn into an animal or mist
and much more this kind of exploration
and progression is linked closely to
Nintendo's Metroid series you may have
heard the term Metroidvania when
referring to games similar to Symphony
of the Night well this is what that's
referring to however Symphony also
adopts many traits similar to an RPG in
addition to leveling up and increasing
your health and MP you'll also be able
to equip different kinds of armor
weapons and accessories to boost your
stats sub weapons also make a return
from previous castlevanias most of which
you'll recognise from those
James as for other things you'll
recognize many of the enemy sprites
inhabiting Dracula's castle came from
previous games it's actually quite
satisfying taking on some of the series
more frustrating enemies with the more
powerful son of Dracula
[Music]
Symphony of the night was also the first
game a Yami Kojima worked on Kojima is a
character designer who is best known for
her elaborate paintings that often adorn
the box art and other materials for the
Castlevania games from this point
forward her work would be seen on many
games and projects within the
Castlevania series Symphony of the Night
is widely regarded as one of the best
games of all time and has seen multiple
read releases over the years just one
year later it was ported to the Sega
Saturn with extra content unfortunately
many considerate and inferior port which
was unusual given the Saturn's
reputation for handling 2d games better
than the PlayStation
it features slowdown in specific areas a
stretched image to fit the increased
resolution and a lack of transparency in
addition to other things however it did
feature new areas and marija as a boss
and playable character in addition
director being playable from the
beginning as opposed to an end game
unlockable the PlayStation version was
also re-released in HD on the Xbox 360
as an Xbox Live Arcade title the first
game on the service to exceed 50
megabytes and of course we have the
version with redone vo that's unlockable
and dracula x chronicles on the PSP
unfortunately at the time of its
original release Symphony of the Night
was not commercially successful
particularly in the u.s. despite that
most games in the series from this point
forward would follow the same formula as
Symphony of the Night however this was
not the case for the forthcoming n64
games
[Music]
following the release of games like
Super Mario 64 and The Legend of Zelda
Ocarina of Time Castlevania 2 tried to
make the jump from 2d gameplay to 3d
levels platforming in action
Castlevania 64 follows Belmont err
Reinhart Schneider and Sipho descendant
Carrie Fernandez as they take on Dracula
if you haven't noticed by now this
entire series involves someone fighting
Dracula because he's an evil dude who
just won't stay dead
courage don't leave me when it comes to
gameplay Castlevania 64 takes a lot of
cues from ocarina of time it utilizes a
lock-on system to target enemies as well
as a first-person mode to view the
environment on top of that your main
attack is governed by the B button while
your secondary attack and sub weapons
are relegated to the C buttons and
instead of an open world or more openly
explorable Castle like in Symphony of
the Night
Castlevania 64 makes use of individual
levels at the time of its release
Castlevania 64 was received favorably
GameSpot's review scored in an eight
point two out of ten saying quote the
developers have done a fantastic job of
capturing the atmosphere and spirit of
the series while providing a
well-balanced challenging gameplay
experience that's filled with pretty
visuals awesome music plenty of Secrets
and some incredible bosses positive
reviews were also written by game pro
egm and IGN despite this praised
castlevania 64 is a contentious game
amongst series fans today with some
loving it
while others hate it some claim that
this is because Castlevania 64 doesn't
necessarily start off on the best foot
the forest of silence is the first level
in the game and is criticized by some
for being too bland
while game spots review said it would
have benefitted from an in-game map
[Music]
another criticism the n64 Castlevania
games get pegged with is that the second
game released later that same year
originally titled Castlevania special
edition legacy of Darkness is a prequel
and reworked version of Castlevania 64
the prequel events star two new
characters Cornell a werewolf that's on
a journey to save his kidnapped sister
and Henry a knight who was saved by
Cornell as a kid and returns to
Dracula's castle to save children in his
own set of levels both are playable and
once certain kids are saved
you'll also unlock Reinhardt and carries
quests from Castlevania 64 now despite
their inclusion some things have been
changed including the removal of the
voice acting on top of that players can
use the n64 expansion pack to increase
the game's resolution this however makes
the framerate jittery as detailed in
GameSpot's review which scored the game
a 7.3 and said its quote exactly what it
sets out to be a better version of the
original before Castlevania re-entered
the 2d plane a 3d action game was being
developed for the Sega Dreamcast
Castlevania resurrection was slated to
star a resurrected Sonya belmonts the
protagonist of the game boys Castlevania
legends and another belmont named victor
it was going to be set prior to the
events of the first Castlevania but was
cancelled in the year 2000 due to the
impending failure of the Dreamcast and
the release of the PlayStation 2
despite Konami looking towards the ps2
it would be more than three years before
Catholic aim to that platform
in the meantime Simon Belmont would
appear in evolution skateboarding as a
playable skater and yes he could fight
Dracula in an appropriately themed level
who's the one who break my silene
he's gonna as for proper Castlevania
games the company set its sights on the
Game Boy Advance with three games that
all followed in the footsteps of
Symphony of the Night
the first was circle of the Moon which
released in 2001 as a launch title for
the GBA this time the protagonist is a
vampire hunter named Nathan graves
though he has no relation to the
Belmonts and does not wield the vampire
killer web what set circle of the Moon
apart from symphony is its magic system
which is called the dual setup system or
DSS for short
you collect cards throughout the castle
that allow you to cast different types
of magic action cards give you your
spell while attribute cards add effects
such as fire ice or plant spores
GameSpot's review gave it a nine point
six out of ten calling it one of the
best portable adventures ever created
the second GBA Castlevania is harmony of
dissonance which released the very next
year in 2002 it set 50 years after the
events of the first Castlevania and
stars Simon Belmont grandson juiced now
it's quite similar to Symphony of the
Night with just sharing many
similarities with Alucard including his
- moves and appearance however it
features two different versions of the
same castle and you'll travel between
them to unlock new areas
GameSpot's review score 9 in 8.2 calling
it easier than circle of the moon but
still great on its own merits
the last castlevania game on the GBA is
2003 Zarya of sorrow it's set after the
events of 1999 s Diamond Castle war the
results of which traps Dracula in a
solar eclipse for all eternity the years
2035 and our star is soma cruise who's
able to absorb the souls of enemies and
use them against other monsters he's
transported to Castlevania along with
his friend Mina who we must save before
she's put into danger he meets multiple
characters along the way including
another Belmont descendant named Julius
he was present during the demon Castle
war being the one who ultimately
in the Lord of Darkness each of these
characters you meet is in the castle due
to a prophecy that was put in place
after Dracula's defeat the mystery of
why soma was transported is one of the
more interesting story elements of the
entire series and much like its
predecessors it's similar in structure
and gameplay to Symphony of the Night
however the soul system adds an
interesting layer think of it as
Castlevania meets Pokemon when soma
kills an enemy he has a chance at
absorbing its soul for example instead
of throwing axes he can throw bones like
the series infamous skeletons after
absorbing their souls other souls allow
him to restore health guard against
attacks and much much more
the metroidvania like abilities that
allow you to access new areas also come
in the form of these souls aria of
sorrow received great critical acclaim
with GameSpot scoring it in eight point
six out of ten and calling it one of the
gbas best action games because of its
success it would receive a direct sequel
though players would have to wait for
the Nintendo DS to arrive first
in the meantime to 3d action games were
on their way
the first was lament of innocence in
2003 which is an origin story that
explains how the Belmonts are destined
to fight dracula for all of eternity
this time the lead Belmont is Leon and
he's on a quest to save his lover Sarah
from a vampire that this time is not
Dracula
of course this is Castlevania so you can
bet we'll see the Lord of Darkness
before the end credits not only is it
the first game chronologically it was
also the first game to feature the newly
designed Castlevania logo that would be
used in every game from this point
forward now lament of innocence does
have a lot of what makes a Castlevania
game truly Castlevania with familiar
enemies sub-weapons destructible candles
and much more however it's more of a
character action game in the vein of
Devil May Cry than any previous entries
in the series and instead of an openly
explorable Castle it features somewhat
of a hub that players can access
multiple areas from this was koji eager
ah she's first time working on a 3d
Castlevania game a task he told GameSpy
was a lot harder than his time on the 2d
games he said quote we've extended a 2-d
game style into 3d but 3d is a very
different environment it's really
obscure comparatively having a 3d
environment is not as precise as it was
with 2d the good point about 3d gaming
is bringing the actual reality based
environment to gaming the dynamics of
audio of the graphics bring a new
reality to life lament of innocence
wasn't quite the smash hit that its
metroidvania counterparts were but it
did receive generally favorable reviews
IGN scored o29 Game Informer in eighth
and GameSpot a seven point seven calling
it a fun though fairly short and simple
game that marks a promising new
beginning for this beloved series it's
follow-up castlevania curse of darkness
released in 2005 on the ps2 and original
Xbox while it kept the 3d game playing
graphics curse of Darkness was a lot
more similar to symphony of the night
than lament of innocence was first off
like a loo card Hector isn't restrained
to a whim and can equip multiple
different weapons curse of darkness also
features an explorable world as opposed
to the squared off levels in lament of
innocence the
map system remains the same from that
game however so don't expect a square
grid like in Symphony of the Night as
for the story
it follows Hector a devil forge master
who betrayed Dracula during Kathleen
eeeh three said a few years after the
events of that game Hector's on a hunt
for fellow forge master Isaac after he
learns that he was behind the murder of
his fiancee as a devil forge master
Hector can create creatures called
innocent Devils which he uses to aid him
in multiple ways for example fairy-type
IDs heal Hector pumpkin types raise luck
and battle types join him in his fight
there are others but they all involve
attacking enemies in a variety of ways
curse of darkness wasn't received quite
as well as lament of innocence though it
did have its fans most of which praised
the battle system GameSpot's review
however scored it a six point eight
calling the level and enemy design
boring critic Greg Kasavin said
Castlevania fans will probably find that
this game gets off to a very promising
start but the good first impression
simply wears off before long game spots
review also noted that while Castlevania
was having a difficult time sticking the
landing on consoles it was thriving on
handhelds prior to curse of Darkness the
first of three Nintendo DS games
released that game was 2005 s
castlevania dawn of sorrow the sequel to
aria of sorrow
[Music]
[Music]
now before we get into dawn of sorrow I
should warn you that I am going to
mention a pretty significant spoiler for
aria so leave now if you don't want the
ending ruin for you
dawn of sorrow has set a year after Aria
and continues sohma's story at the end
of Aria we discovered that soma is
actually the reincarnation of Dracula
which prompts an evil cult to try and
take control of him or extract his dark
power and implanted in a new host
effectively resurrecting the Lord of
Darkness the gameplay is very similar to
Aria continuing on with the soul system
one new addition however takes advantage
of the DS's touchscreen the magic seal
system requires players to draw the
pattern on the touchscreen to trap a
boss's soul if you fail in drawing the
pattern you have to fight the boss a bit
more before getting another chance this
particular feature wasn't received well
but overall the game was welcomed with
much critical acclaim
GameSpot's review scored it in 8.9
saying quote it sticks close to the
tried and true formula so it will be an
instant hit for anyone with an affinity
for the sort of explorative gameplay the
series is known for the next es game
released a year later in 2006 portrait
of ruin is a sequel to the Sega Genesis
game bloodlines as it stars John
Morris's son Jonathan and his witch
friend Charlotte it set years after the
events of that game where it's revealed
that John Morris died after his battle
with Dracula in bloodlines at the start
of portrait of ruin however it's unknown
as to why meanwhile Jonathan has
inherited the vampire killer whip but is
unable to master it and use its true
power which is why you'll equip more
than just the fabled whip throughout the
duration of the game as for the story
well Jonathan and Charlotte discovered
that Dracula's castle has been revived
once again thanks to the vampire Lord
Bronner who plans to wreak havoc in
Dracula's absence Jonathan and Charlotte
meet a mysterious ghostly figure who
assists the two in their fight against
Bronner once again this handheld entry
was very similar to Symphony of the
Night you could play as both main
characters switching between them on the
fly or fighting together at once while
controlling one character the other will
be driven by AI to contribute attacks
there are also specific spells that
you'll need both characters to be
present for
Jonathan Morris is what you'd expect
from a castlevania protagonist at this
point with whips swords and other
weapons at his disposal while Charlotte
uses spell books to summon weapons and
other spells
additionally the to discover that
they'll need to enter magical paintings
to destabilize the castles power each
painting features its own world lending
a bunch of different themes and locales
in contrast to the Gothic castle
aesthetic portrait of Rouen was also
well received with GameSpot's reviews
saying it was great not because of what
it does differently but because it quote
stays true to the familiar castlevania
design and delivers a fun lengthy
adventure both dawn of sorrow and
portrait of ruin adopted a more anime
influenced art style as opposed to a
Yamaka dima's character designs however
the final castlevania DS game would
adopt a gothic art style designed by
Misaki Haruka 2008 order of ecclesia is
set after the events of Symphony of the
night when the Belmonts have disappeared
leaving many to form their own groups to
dispel Dracula and other evil beings one
of these is the order of ecclesia of
which the protagonist Chenoa is a member
of as someone who can wield magical
glyphs which are basically this games
version of weapons she is chosen to be
the wielder of Dominus a glyph that's
powerful enough to defeat Dracula
however her friend Albus is angered by
not being chosen himself so he prevents
the ritual and seriously hurts Chenoa
causing her to lose all memory and
emotion once she awakens she must go on
a quest to stop Albus and reclaim
Dominus the combat is similar to past
games though instead of weapons you'll
use glyphs these glyphs are acquired
similarly to souls in dawn of sorrow
killing specific enemies will give you
specific weapons for example if you kill
a sword wielding skeleton you'll have a
chance to absorb a sword glyph
[Music]
once absorbed you'll then be able to
attack with that weapon and because
glyphs are technically magic you'll
consume mana when using them
however mana recharges much faster than
previous games making it more like
stamina than actual mana on top of that
ecclesia features multiple different
locations each with their own square
based grid map as opposed to one single
castle you'll traverse the world
visiting each location by selecting them
on a map with new areas showing up once
you make your way through others Weigel
village acts as somewhat of a hub with
shops and other people calling it home
however they've been kidnapped by Elvis
so you'll have to rescue them before you
can buy their wares once rescued you'll
also be able to complete quests for them
that will grant you new items to buy now
order of ecclesia is notable for its
harder difficulty critics praised this
in addition to some of its unique
mechanics
GameSpot's reviews scored it in 8.5 and
said it's streamlined level design and
versatile combat system make this the
most engaging Castlevania gaming years
unfortunately order of ecclesia would be
the last game in the series that went
full bore with the Symphony of the Night
format later games would feature
exploration of this kind but not to the
extent that these games are known and
loved for
[Music]
the next game Castlevania judgment
released in 2008 exclusively for the Wii
it's a 3d fighting game that features
many of the characters throughout the
series history from Simon and Trevor
Belmont to Grant dinasty and Eric
Lockhart however they feature radically
different designs as instead of a Yami
Kojima's classic artwork judgment uses
designs created by Death Note artist
Takeshi Obata unfortunately the game was
very poorly received by critics with
GameSpot's reviews scoring it a 3 out of
10 the review said quote the
unforgiveable flaws drained nearly every
ounce of enjoyment from judgment and
whatever aspiration it had falls flat on
its face the abhorrent camera dreadful
art and cumbersome controls are for
masochistic applicants only fans of the
franchise fighting or fun will find
nothing of value in this sloppy cash in
the same year a teaser trailer for a new
Castlevania game was shown at the Tokyo
Game Show and it was Konami z-- first
attempt at rebooting the series the game
was set to release for the ps3 and 360
and feature
Alucard is the protagonist however it
was never heard from again
[Music]
fast forward two more years and we're in
2010 it was a big year for Castlevania
with the release of three different
games
the first was Castlevania puzzle encore
of the night which was a favorably
received puzzle game that featured
similar art to what was used in Symphony
of the Night and released exclusively on
iOS with a Windows Phone release coming
a year later the second was castlevania
harmony of despair a digital Xbox Live
Arcade game that focused on multiplayer
the story involves an enchanted book
that carries the story of Castlevania
Dracula's castle comes to life and
brings together characters from across
the series history with it the playable
characters at launch were a low card
soma Cruz Jonathan Morris Charlotte O
lean and Chenoa downloadable content
introduced even more characters such as
belmonts richter simon and julius up to
six players can fight Dracula's minions
together online and while you can roam
the castle freely no matter where any of
the other players are you will be able
to perform more powerful attacks when
fighting together
unfortunately the Xbox Live Arcade
version did not feature local co-op but
the ps3 version that released a year
later did the multiplayer focused
harmony of despair received mixed
reviews GameSpot scored at a seven point
five out of ten and said it doesn't give
a good first impression
but harmony of despair delivers new and
exciting gameplay opportunities for an
old series the review pointed to the
cooperative gameplay and challenge as
high points at this point in
castlevanias history konami was looking
to reboot the series despite the
fantastic praise and passionate fan base
castlevania wasn't selling as well as
the company would have liked through a
prototype and pitch period konami
decided to move forward with a project
created by developer mercury steam the
project was actually an original IP
before it was greenlit as a castlevania
game the project was cancelled early on
in development but as NTV reported back
in 2010 producer David Cox showed the
game to Konami Japan and got help from
Metal Gear Solid creator Hideo Kojima
which helped set the game back on course
now the original pitch was to remake the
first Castlevania but it was
completely decided that mercury steam
would reboot the series entirely
castlevania lords of shadow is what the
team ended up with
lords of Shadow stars Gabriel Belmont
played by The Full Monty actor Robert
Carlyle Gabriel is a member of the
Brotherhood of light in order of knights
that wage war against monsters Gabriel's
wife Marie is killed by one of these
monsters and with her soul in limbo
Gabriel sets out to kill the lords of
shadow and bring her back from the dead
along the way he meets the oldest living
member of the Brotherhood of lights a
man named zou back that's played by
Patrick Stewart who is also the game's
narrator mankind faces ruin and despair
the world is changing yet hope remains
in the hearts of the people we go about
our daily lives never knowing the forces
that can change our destinies forever
we are oblivious ignorant like sheep to
the slaughter lords of Shadow revolves
mostly around a style of character
action combats in linear levels where
the player swings their whip around both
for targeting single enemies at a time
and entire groups enemies include
creatures such as vampires werewolves
and goblins but every now and then
you'll come across a gargantuan sized
boss called it Titan you'll use your
whip to grapple onto their large bodies
traverse them and smash their runes to
take them down
its new direction wasn't a huge hit with
all fans but lords of Shadow was
received quite well by critics both game
informer and joysticks courted a 9
Eurogamer awarded it an 8 and GameSpot
gave it a 7.5 GameSpot review praised
its graphics combat and voice acting but
lamented its camera puzzles and
derivative nature as for its sales lords
of Shadow was a commercial success and
its first month it sold more than 1
million copies and eventually became the
best-selling game in the series konami
was happy with the sales and decided to
move forward with two more games in the
lords of shadow sub series now if you
care about spoilers for the first Lords
of shadow then now is the time to stop
watching
seek the guardian of the lake I was paid
to him but we must be quick climb into
my bag honey the first of these sequels
was lords of shadow mirror of fate which
initially released on the 3ds in 2013
before getting ported in HD to ps3 and
360 later that year mirror of fate
features four playable characters during
different moments in time Gabriel
Belmont is playable during the prologue
then we get control of trevor belmont
Simon Belmont and a loo card over the
course of the rest of the game
now lords of Shadow was a 3d action game
similar to God of War but mirror of fate
takes the series back to 2d this time
with 3d graphics however unlike its
other 2d handheld brethren it focuses
much more on combat than exploration
mirror of faith story starts with
Gabriel Belmont fighting the Demon Lord
one year before the events of the first
Lords of shadow during this time his
wife Marie gives birth to Trevor in
secret but the Brotherhood pushes her to
hide him from Gabriel as they already
know he's destined to become Dracula
which is revealed at the end of lords of
shadow years later Trevor and cypher
give birth to Simon and are killed at
the hands of Dracula
[Music]
Simon is raised by barbarians and vows
to get revenge on the vampire Lord we
also get sections where we play as a
Luca and Trevor Belmont who we learn are
the same people in the lords of shadow
universe trevor falls to dracula during
their battle at which point he reveals
himself as Dracula's son the lord of
darkness then prevents his son from
dying by turning him into a vampire
marking his coffin with the word a loo
card at this point players had already
experienced the aftermath of Alucard
awakening in the previous act
GameSpot's review criticized the story
for being predictable as it's told in
Reverse and some big clues diminish the
surprise but critic Peter Brown did
appreciate that it defied the
established history of the Belmonts he
also praised the combo heavy combat and
2d gameplay for working well together in
addition to the variety of challenges
provided within the castles walls
however the QuickTime events were a
sticking point that lessened the
experience King spots review scored it a
7 out of 10 later that year the ps3 and
360 versions released with a visual
boost and without many of those actions
stealing QuickTime events thanks to
these changes those versions received an
8 out of 10
mirror of faith served as somewhat of a
stopgap between the first and second
lords of Shadow castlevania lords of
Shadow 2 released on ps3 360 and PC in
2014
[Music]
miserable pile of secrets this time
you're playing is dracula for the first
time in the series of course since
Gabriel Belmont is Dracula you've
already kind of played as him but
nevertheless you now have Dracula like
powers the combat is similar to the
first game sticking to the character
action style of gameplay however Dracula
can use the blood of his enemies to take
advantage of the void in chaos which
grant him temporary access to special
weapons
the former gives him the void sword
which heals him with each hit on an
enemy while the latter equips them with
claws that can pierce through an enemy's
defenses as for the story it starts with
the Brotherhood of light seeing
Dracula's castle moments before Dracula
kills all of them and is confronted by a
luke card
Alucard and Dracula come up with a plan
to give Dracula the sweet release of
true death that he's always wanted in an
attempt to trick Satan into thinking
Dracula is dead
Alucard stabs his father with a sword
that puts him into a centuries-long
sleep the rest of the game is set in
modern day though Dracula has no memory
of why he was put to rest it pleases me
to see you recovered o friend
indeed our guest is just a little
confused I know what he wants
Sobek who is now an enemy warns dracula
of scenes returned and gives him the
vampire killer whiff you know the enemy
of my enemy is my friend that whole
thing dracula must now set out to kill
those who wish to summon Satan while
fighting the modern day brotherhood of
light which is now led by his descendant
victor bal mons unfortunately the
conclusion to the lords of Shadow series
was not received as favorably as past
games while it did garner positive
reviews from some outlets the reception
was largely mixed Destructoid and IGN
gave the game a 6.5 while Game Informer
gave it a 6
GameSpot's review awarded it a 7 though
said it should have been a much shorter
game critic Peter Brown criticized the
stealth sections and weak start but
praised its beautiful gothic world
impressive enemy and boss designs and
satisfying conclusion to the lords of
Shadow trilogy
unfortunately lords of Shadow 2 was the
last new Castlevania game to be released
it's been more than four years and
there's been no word on a brand new
entry Konami is not the video game
publishing force it once was with the
cancellation of silent hill's removal of
PT from the PlayStation Store and
falling out with Hideo Kojima Konami has
released very few games this generation
and while Konami has been in the
gambling business for quite some time
the company has since become infamous
for its slot and pachinko machines based
on its beloved franchises Castlevania is
no stranger to these machines now aside
from Pachi slot where is Castlevania in
2018 while Konami announced a new mobile
game that's set to release later this
year but thankfully that's not the most
noteworthy thing
Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse was
adapted into a Netflix series in 2017
and was well received by fans and
critics alike its second season debuts
on October 26 the same day konami
releases castlevania requiem a
collection that bundles both symphony of
the night
and Rondo of blood on the ps4 but that's
not it's both Simon and Richter Belmont
are playable in Super Smash Bros
ultimate in addition to the fighter
having a stage based on Dracula's castle
while on this stage you can get items by
hitting candles in between various
monsters from the series making
appearances Dracula will even show up at
times wreaking havoc on anyone who gets
in his way and to the surprise of many
kid Dracula was even teased during a
Nintendo Direct but we're not exactly
sure how he'll factor in and on top of
all that Smash Bros ultimate features a
loo card as an assist trophy as well as
34 brand new arrangements of classic
Castlevania songs over the years
castlevanias influence has been seen
throughout various games both indie and
triple-a alike 2018 in particular has
seen a large influx of these including
dead cells chasm and much more with all
of that and the various other
Castlevania goodies this year proves
there's still plenty of love for the
series whether we'll see a new adventure
well that remains to be seen but you can
be sure that fans are eagerly awaiting
Dracula's next resurrection
[Music]